I've heard that you want to keep it a
little more intimate we know max had a
huge wedding and you're kind of trying
to keep it a little tighter is that true
I'm just trying to save some money you
know so the less invites I could send
out the better vows Murkowski and fiance
Jenna Johnson's big day is coming
together have you guys set a date are
you getting any closer to it uh yeah I
mean we have kind of the time like the
month of it I mean we're narrow down to
month so which is which is thank you now
that you've been engaged for a few
months what's the biggest difference
with fiance like my vows on the third
time it's like start crying
Victoria losing her composure is one
reason the couple might not consider her
for this role on their big day I asked
her considering you know she's such good
friends with you and with Jenna would
she officiate the wedding
no she thinks she's not worthy I'm a SAP
no way she's more than worthy I just as
you could tell she's not very excited
about it
I would straight-up crying I'm such a
SAP at wedding legs give out yeah
challenge itself that you can officiate
my wedding whomever you all right
Brooklyn spin will be right there
perfect fit right in
you